[Musique]
bokassa laisser l'hôtel zidane
asseyez-vous merci pour le jingle
vraiment vous êtes en forme en régie
aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus de lumière
jeu on ne peut plus avec sa déco dès le
trimestre le deuxième trimestre touche
bientôt à sa fin le deuxième trimestre
de touche pas à mon poste
capucine à naves vous êtes une des
nouvelles recrues ne touche pas à mon
poste cette année et ils vont tous vous
mettre des notes vous aussi un sur
twitter est également des appréciations
sur twitter et sur facebook
alors entre zéro et 2 c exclusion
immédiate 3,5
avertissements 6 et 8 encouragements ou
9/10 félicitations il peut avoir d
exclusion est parti avec un petit
immédiate exclusion immédiate c'est une
fusion immédiate gars vous prenez vos
valises tak tak badaboum
merci par ici la sortie alors attention
on va voir tous les notes de tout le
monde et on va démarrer par la note de
thierry moreau apprendra les notes de
tout le monde alors on va faire un petit
résumé d'abord de capucine à naves
ce sera dans un instant vous reste avec
nous pour le conseil de classe et on va
voir si capucines à la va être exclu du
collège avec 800 cv
[Applaudissements]
elle est basée à dallas
quelques têtes sculptées dans cette
chanson qu'est ce qu'ils disent or des
bazars d'alice bazardiers va là bas vous
connaissiez sa voiture de l'aumône
non mais ça vous arrivez à les jeunes et
les séries avec chéri celle en conseil
de classe de capucine à naves et ensuite
bien sûr on va revenir sur tout ce qui
s'est passé à la télé on aura le conseil
de classe aussi de laurence boccolini
tout à l'heure dans le top 3 avec notre
équipe et on aura une grosse info de
thierry moreau qui vient de tomber et il
a une info imprécises et importante à
nous donner tout à l'heure concernant le
pass paysage audiovisuel français
merci eshiro tout cas d'internet en
direct via bouder qui me dit que
napoléon aussi mon bouder mon frère mon
frérot napoléon deal avec psa ouais la
1re cat et napoléon oui enfin il y en a
d'autres qui étaient salamé cms naboléon
qu'a vécu un passé le pas c'est pas
aurait 4 africa faut aussi l'accord
foutez vous de ma gueule maintenant
aller le deuxième trimestre donc tous à
sa faim capucine anna vous allez avoir
les notes de tous les chroniqueurs de
vous également chez vous c'est parti on
va voir on a fait un petit résumé de
toutes vos prestations en regard des
capucins de martial
[Musique]
enfin et oui ni non tapez si l on y va
aller 30 secondes
oui si tu veux bien fait une sextape oui
oui vous série go vous êtes déjà filmé
bah ouais
capitale des états unis new york la
capitale de la bulgarie
je sais pas c'est une gare du gard donne
des maux du bord on dit dans quelle
ville ils sont venus mène en chine vous
savez comment on peut sortir autochtones
[Applaudissements]
je vous promets
capelli banane c'est son conseil de
classe vous devez mettre une note de 0 à
10 avec une appréciation et vous aussi
et on aura la note globale et on verra
qui est le meilleur élève de ce deuxième
trimestre dont quinze jours maintenant
puisque tout le monde y passera je vous
le dis bien voilà donc thierry moreau
votre note est votre appréciation pour
capucine allah vous avez une petite
pente pas vous avez une ardoise tout ça
merci il est réveillé
4 pourquoi peut mieux faire pour son
rire essentiellement il ya au moins
trois points sur les quatre qui sont on
sent rien parce qu'elle a vraiment à
rire incroyable pour sa plastique quand
même parce que voilà pour le reste qui
est un peu de regret faire d'accord vous
êtes dur ah oui un peu ouais je suis
juste d'accord c'est ça alors 4e
isabelle morini bosc alors certains
migrants votre note cet ennemi moi oui
alors certains disent méchamment qu'elle
a plus d'esprit l'équipe que d'esprit
tout court moi je trouve que c'est
méchant faut qu'elle a énormément de
fraîcheur de gentillesse de de candeur
qu'elle apporte beaucoup à l'équipe a en
bon esprit un bon état d'esprit
et puis donc un vrai plus alors le petit
moins qu à puce et l'orthographe et
leurs taux bas c'est vraiment bon
[Applaudissements]
je
des lacunes ya des lacunes en
orthographe au niveau de la syntaxe est
pas tout à fait ça pour les capitales
l'une que l'autre pour l'orthographe
voilà vous avez set et demi et j'ai un
beau bouquet plus in merci c'était
auront alors on ne donne pas d'avis
personae dans un conseil de classe
vous voyez l'épreuve le prof
d'histoire-géo j'aime beaucoup monsieur
rougemont sourire énorme et non ça
suffit vraiment moi alors moi j'ai mis
ça non mais oh non c'est pas de beyrouth
comme le nombre de chance qu'elle a de
faire quelque chose et expliqué je pense
qu'elle ce qu'on voit c'est vrai à la
ramasse elle a remis ça fait un mois que
je la connais sa ferme wasquehal à la
ramasse bogota capitale des états unis à
lomé est d'après moi pour avoir bossé un
mois avec elle c'est par moi je vis avec
elle je la vois en coulisses je la vois
dans les loges j'ai l'impression à 80 %
qu'elle est en train de nous prendre
tous pour des cons à sait très bien ce
qu'elle m'a pourquoi tu mets 0 ce qui
excède pas parce que je te mets 0 sur ce
que tu me donnes sur ce que tu montres
je te mets 0 mais j'ai l'impression que
tu prends tout le monde pour des cons
parce qu'ils étaient plus intelligente
et on est tous nos comptes quelqu'un et
crois moi je sais mathieu n'est pas de
cet avis auparavant
alors oui donc non moi je pense qu elle
est très intelligente elle le fait
exprès mais avant la laisse un petit
mais je pense qu'elles fixent alors
géraldine maillet vôtre alors moi je dis
thème ici ça a été un comme cocteau ce
qu'on te reproche cultive le sétois même
comme le comme cocteau le commandant
cocteau
un livre que j'ai lu et c'est une lettre
d'une inconnue vrai way comment
jaroussky j'allais dire mais deux
alors comme disait cocteau disait quoi
jean cocteau rythme et bien ce qu'on te
reproche cultive le puisque c'est toi
même alors je dirais deux choses je vais
te parler comme s'ils étaient machy
puisqu'en fait à peu près la moitié de
mon âge
donc je vais dire c'est avec tendresse
avec affection avec bienveillance mais
je veux mieux et plus pour toi
alors évidemment tape l'inde aspects
très positifs t'es gentil était
souriante et bienveillante et bien élevé
un très bon esprit était très camarades
très bonne camarade donc ça c'est très
agréable pour les côtés négatifs je
dirais juste que tu vois
valérie pour les côtés négatifs on
attend du côté négatif je trouve que tu
as tellement peur de rater que tu rates
que tu manques de concentration quand tu
te précipites beaucoup et je trouve que
tu as beaucoup de followers beaucoup
trop fort le follower million à un
million
alors je pense que tu devrais leur
donner un peu de contenu maintenant bon
lol ah ouais quand j'avais et non mais
c'est très sérieux à ce conseil de
classe ou noyés et c'est ça qu'on aime
attention benjamin castaldi la note pour
capucine alnot économie 8 arrêts bravo
la méchante ouais quand on passe les
sept c'est un peu plus sur la personne
connaît on embrasse la mère de benjamin
s'était d'abord je n' ai donné ses
méthodes
après c'est vrai que j'avais l'image
d'une jeune fille un peu bête à bouffer
des guêpes sage de reconnaître même fait
du foie aussi ça y est j'ai déjà fait du
x est aussi voilà mais à vous mettez
deux fois et de guêpe deux fois rien
mais en revanche je trouve que c'est
effectivement une très bonne camara sur
quel bon esprit et je trouve qu'elle
joue très bien ce rôle de de candeur
voilà dans l'émission après c'est vrai
je mets un bémol
et ça parce que pour l'instant ça nous
fait rire et c'est drôle mais plus tard
ça pourra faire - restera beaucoup en
gros c'est la culture générale et là je
suis très sérieux il faut tu apprennes
un minimum tu vois les pressions la
république les capitales héliographique
histoire parce que par alain à dire d
énorme bêtise mais à part ça honnêtement
tu as tes traits à l'antenne et je pense
que tout ira très loin si tu travailles
un peu plus sa piscine
capucine d'ailleurs tiens qui est de
personnes souffrent qui est le premier
ministre actuellement donne à 15,9
bravo jamais vraiment mais le métal est
habile à dire françois fillon et valérie
daniel moreau alors moi j'ai mis 5 c'est
un peu difficile parce que pour
l'instant ce n'est pas beaucoup mais bon
c'est mitigé parce que vous partez quand
même avec deux gros handicap vous avez
fait de la télé réalité et vous êtes
quand même sublime et ça c'est super
énervant donc on s'est dit c'est super
énervant pour les autres filles donc
forcément au départ on vous déteste ça
c'est sûr donc ça c'est le côté négatif
mais on regarde l'émission je vous
trouve bien vu vous avez envie
d'apprendre
je n'ai pas mal de choses à prendre en
même temps donc c'est facile et puis
vous êtes super sensible mois parfois
vous mettez les larmes aux yeux quand
vous êtes ému dans l'émission d'ondés
c'est le côté positif
le truc c'est bonne camarade le
producteur se colorer guily ça va ce
parti né le feu
on se prend alors la mère regarde ça
fait qu'on prendrait peut-être pas mais
joslet merci elle a donc voila et le
côté négatif c'est bonne camarade non
parce que imaginez si on si on se
promène dans la rue toutes les deux et
bien se passe déjà que j'arrive pas à
draguer quand je suis tout seul ou avec
ma mère alors avec vous ces voraces au
fait vous n'avez jamais l'autre on la
voit comme ça jamais on croirait la main
à la tête
non
non mais ça non mais jamais battre on
lui demande de mettre une note à
quelqu'un elle a une sauce balade dans
la rue c'est waou bonne camarade je suis
désolé il faudrait qu'elle serait vain
un oeil ou un truc c'est tout cas en
tout cas vous aimez les gens voient leur
casque revendeurs francoeur et mcclatchy
c'est apparemment allée merci en tout
cas mais vous vous êtes à fond
ça fait combien de temps que vous n'avez
pas pechoux un mec oh là là celui qui
m'a vu nuit les il est vieux et des
questions sur sa fait furmark homme là
est la grand-mère qui a pas vu lui
combien combien très longtemps mais
genre en année en deux ans mais on
décennies les cinq ans viendrait encore
50 ans et maintenant je le fais par
jouer lire en fête ce qui est un vieil
basez vous parler c'était quelle voiture
dans les rues basez-vous par rapport aux
choses que vous voyez dans la rue mais
encore le minitel où vous ne venez pas
fait l'amour est encore moins ah bah oui
mais je prenais sûr mais on ait pas de
vices fait pareil mais heureusement je
profite de cette tribune parce que quand
même bon on a bien comprise
et
médias merci on a lancé un appel vous
inquiétez pas on va trouver on va
trouver quelqu'un à l'art inquiétant
cela dit vous avez pas l'air inquiète
banon sur la terre est passé à un moment
je vais dire c'est comme le facteur
moment s'il vient plutôt foot mais je
reconnais que ça va être pareil
le facteur il frappe plus chez nous vu
la dernière fois on l'a séquestrée
pendant 8 jours pour une fois qu'il y
avait un homme qui frappait à la maison
[Applaudissements]
la fusée mijaurée way l hôtel nous sort
le blâme mais comment cela pète elle est
là c'est assez le média c'est le côté
des mannequins entre matthieu delormeau
géraldine ces bordels aller non
pour catherine allard retrait du cube
puis sam le niveau est bien trop faible
vous réussissez l'export deux heures
d'émission de ne jamais prononcer une
seule parole sensée au nom j'ai beaucoup
hésité entre admiration et consternation
et la consternation l'a largement
emporté
je vous mets un essai généreux il est
dur avant d'avoir la note des
téléspectateurs mais mathieu mathieu oui
ce que demi merci à moi sert à rien
alors vous capucine ma chérie à thann
est non il donnera sans doute après tu
es un corps sain dans un esprit vide et
tu sais ce que c'est niveau analyse
médias merci niveau analyse immédiate et
un petit peu comme tout comme son ex
beau père aux élections était à la rue
ma chérie et où je dis ce que je veux
c'est mon moment ça va
non non voilà c'est le livre sexy quand
il s'énerve comme ça ne me daniel anon
alors là
nadal
et aurait d'ailleurs va pas se moquer
des mecs tous les soirs très bien on ne
vit pas du même côté de l'arrivée ça
c'est que cette fin bisous en avoir une
rivière au retour
[Applaudissements]
sur capucine calvet dur capucines on
connaît votre culture générale ma chérie
je te dis franchement je n'imaginais pas
que ça pouvait exister à ce point là
comme confidences et quelques semaines
elle m'a dit je quand on est athée pmp
ça me permet de redorer mon blouson
voilà c'est pas grave rien dit rgo
raymond plus heureux de raymond blouson
est ce qu on peut battre le générique et
vous continuez jusqu'à oui j'ai encore
d'autres choses à dire a bien sûr
accepté les gens disent et on aura là
bas ça sa perception des choses
et quelle fut la section générique puis
tu à bouffer c'est parti oui j'ai des
répliques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
matthieu delormeau on reprend direct a
alors mathieu donc capucines à votre
appréciation sur capital conseille
d'être honnête et là j'avais trois
premiers points bon autres points il ya
un truc que en revanche que tu maîtrises
mais la télévision c'est que ça va que
tu comprends rien c'est à dire chez 90%
du temps d'émission tuerie fort as-tu
ricci ricci rigole du coup ça passe pas
mal c'est la maquette ces saletés assez
bien est-ce qu alors tu mènes mire
énormément et je le comprends tu me l'a
souvent dit parce que tu me vois
beaucoup mais tu m'as denis rossi
physiquement parce qu'on écoute ou les
deux mais attention bébé il y à du
contenu dans le contenant ne l'oublient
jamais son nom sinon un jour tu peux
avoir pardon mais l'effet bandjéli c'est
à dire on rigole on rigole et puis un
jour là mot de passe et puis il ya plus
rien attention à ça mais dernier point
c'est là où je t'envoie cinq ans en
conseil de classe à l'autre qu'on l'a
ce sera la bretagne ce sera la semaine
prochaine vous un cas d'école attendant
leur bus à l'année précédente il a perdu
beaucoup de points tu es une grosse
allumeuse samaras ne sert d'allumer
cyril mais tu crois que je n'ai pas vu
depuis le début de l'émission alors
l'hôte évidemment cela qui fait le con
temps et voilà c'est pas qu'on allume se
décrochent un prime en trois semaines
que j'ai pas eu un seul oiseau jeu les
boîtes se suffisent c'était tout ça
c'était c'était magouille et compagnie
les remontées chaudes tous ses déboires
mais je ne le tolérerai pas du tout
sinon c'était le jeu eh oui on dit
qu'alberto est bon ton monte à demander
quel que soit mon président m'a jamais
ta bêtise et maintenant c'est une
émission ou alors on essaie chroniqueur
alors est née autour d'elle
évidemment il est content oui c'est la
petite allumeuse dès lors pour ça ma
chérie voilà j'ai comme était gentil
parce que je me souviens malgré tout que
je t'ai fait tu as 5 ha ça va je pensais
moi voilà c'est vrai et capucine n'a
jamais allumée personnel
bonjour alors mais ça vient ça ainsi
qu'à public mais lui non tu oses raconte
les pubs madagascar et c'est pas les
mains pendant les pubs et de céréales
avec quoi c'est à moi qui est celui qui
voulait me bauer et matthew les hôtels
où le mythe heureusement j'arrive
pourquoi il ment tout le temps mais
c'est ce que parce que c'est sa nature
même son iconique voilà c'est incroyable
le leinster rien d'intelligente ou mytho
on va voir la note de capucine adav qu'à
la note alors des chroniqueurs 4,6 sur
10 et vous la note que vous avez mis un
bien sûr les téléspectateurs et bien la
note des twittos c'est les deux et l est
de l
merci bah oui banier vous le cul
anna des tutos ce n'est pas par aman lé
2 0-3 mais les de 4,2 la note détruit la
gauche donc ce qui fait notre général de
4,4 sur 10 pour capucine adam notre
petit de feu à tous bravo capucine la
piscine du coup vous avez un
avertissement de travail capucines à
naves à 4,4 quatre avertissements
travail
voilà vous vous y attendiez bah non pas
trop et ben voilà vous avez un
avertissement remercie qu'a pu faire un
bilan
[Applaudissements]